the presidential election is four weeks
from today the latest poll numbers
suggest Donald Trump has a mountain to
climb Hillary Clinton leads Trump by 11
points 46 to 35%
when third-party candidates are included
the poll was taken after the release of
video of Trump making vulgar comments
about women the same poll gave Clinton a
six-point lead last month Trump
campaigned yesterday across the
battleground state of Pennsylvania
claiming victory in Sunday's debate
major Garrett is here with the
Republican nominees new urgency major
good morning good morning Donald Trump
did what politicians do when they are in
a real tight Jam ignore bad poll numbers
and if you can look for a cute kid in
the crowd and then a cameraman Trump who
generally can't stop talking about those
hosts horserace poll numbers well he
couldn't find one to mention yesterday
Donald Trump careened from light-hearted
campaign stick do you want to go back to
them and do you want to stay with Donald
Trump to cliched confrontation oh she's
crooked folks she's crooked as a $3 bill
as he always does Trump declared himself
the victor at Sunday's debate I was
getting beaten up for 72 hours on all
the networks Trump treaded lightly
around his vulgar and sexist comments
about women in 2005 and redirected the
controversy and former President Bill
Clinton's direction Bill Clinton
sexually assaulted innocent women and
Hillary Clinton attacked those women
viciously in the video that continues to
rock the campaign Trump laughs about
trying to seduce entertainment reporter
Nancy O'Dell I couldn't get there last
night Odell broke her silence about
Trump there is no room for
objectification of women or anyone for
that matter not even in the locker room
a recent poll found more than half of
registered voters believe Trump's
comments should be an issue in the
campaign over a third say they
disqualified Trump from the presidency
running mate Mike Pence said on Saturday
Trump's remarks quote offended him and
declined for two days to publicly defend
after the debate hence climbed back on
board he fought back and turned the
focus to the choice that we face and I'm
proud to stand with Donald Trump now
rumors have been swirling that more
outtakes from Trump's hit show The
Apprentice could be released causing
still more trouble for Trump and in a
statement yesterday Mark Burnett the
show's producer said legally the media
company is restricted from releasing any
such material deal but those always
always those tapes always seem to find
the light of day even with all the legal
restrictions Nora yeah I was gonna say
exactly you're saying even if he's
restricted somebody may leak those tapes
right somebody who's doesn't feel so
restricted yeah that's right Thank You
major